de l'autre l'ordinateur à l'école se
généralise avec tout de même des petits
vernis avant les autres dans certains
collèges des landes chaque élève a reçu
son ordinateur portable prix 1500 euros
soit dix mille francs
c'est le conseil général des landes qui
a décidé de cette opération david bazié
vincent pacifique en du premier au
dernier rang sur chaque table des
ordinateurs portables reliés aux grands
tableaux interactifs du professeur ses
élèves de 3e du collège jean moulin de
saint paul les dax sont en cours
d'histoire lors qu'il ya des mots bleus
comme le mot marque si c'est vous
cliquez dessus
vous avez une explication qui s'affiche
d'accord par souci d'égalité je ne
faisais jamais faire un travail sur une
encyclopédie
sachant que certains pourraient le faire
à la maison donc ne courait pas
maintenant je peux le faire puisqu'ils
ont tous encyclopédie dans leur machine
donc tous au même niveau chacun tient
c'est le conseil général des landes qui
payent le département envisage de verser
10 millions d'euros par an pour équiper
chaque collégien landais l'opération est
financièrement lourde mais c'est au nom
de la démocratisation de l'accès à
l'informatique ont fait un test sur
trois collèges pas faire d'internet de
généraliser ce qui ferait 14 mille
élèves
moi je pense mais ça je les dis par
ailleurs que la france ne doit pas
laisser ce cri une fracture numérique et
que l'équipement et l'accès à internet
devrait être érigée en mission de
service public le test menée dans ce
collège devra répondre à beaucoup de
questions
trouvez les logiciels capables de
remplacer les livres scolaires éprouver
la solidité du matériel et sa sécurité
sachant que chaque élève emporte
l'ordinateur à la maison c'est une
préoccupation de toutes les personnes
qui ont une connaissance du dossier
c'est presque une
c'est la première question qui
qui vient à l'esprit des gens mais est
ce que vous avez pensé aux vols ou
rackets haut alors on a essayé de penser
à beaucoup de choses
maintenant on verra sur les trois
collèges test pour la généralisation de
l'an prochain un premier bilan sera
établi dans deux mois une chose est sûre
au collège jean moulin de saint paul les
dax
les élèves ne chahute plus dans les
couloirs